bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regardant
direct journée très particulière à
l'Assemblée nationale sur laquelle on va
revenir avec notre grand témoin ce soir
bonsoir Éric Coquerel bonsoir vous êtes
le président de la commission des
finances merci de passer leur avec nous
on va commencer par revenir sur ce qui
s'est passé à Annecy bien sûr il était
9h45 ce matin lorsqu’un homme a
poignardé plusieurs personnes dont de
très petits enfants près du lac tous
sont en urgence absolue ce soir la
Nation toute entière et sous le choc on
va revenir évidemment sur les faits sur
les réactions politiques certains
parlent déjà de récupération avec mes
invités dans un tout petit instant une
attaque effroyable qui s'est évidemment
invité dans l'hémicycle les députés ont
observé une minute de silence alors
qu'il débattait de la proposition de loi
visant à abroger la réforme des
retraites privées de vote faute de
recevabilité les oppositions ont fait
entendre leur colère vous allez voir
elle était vive la démocratie
parlementaire a-t-elle été écrabouillée
comme on a pu l'entendre grand débat
avec nos invités dans la deuxième partie
vous retrouverez bien sûr vos
rendez-vous les partis pris nos
affranchis à la fin de cette émission
voilà pour le programme ce soir on y va
Eric Coquerel ça vous regarde c'est
parti
[Musique]
la terreur à Annecy l'homme que vous
allez voir est un réfugié si rien de 32
ans il s'est attaqué ce matin armée d'un
couteau à six personnes donc quatre
enfants de 22 à 36 mois dans le quartier
du paquet au bord du lac d'Annecy tout
ce soir sauf un adulte sont en urgence
absolue attaque sans mobile terroriste
apparent selon les premiers éléments de
l'enquête enquête ouverte pour tentative
d'assassinatoires Mathieu Lefebvre et
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes député
renaissance du Val-de-Marne bonsoir
Philippe Balard bonsoir bienvenue député
rassemblement national de l'Oise bonsoir
Pierre Cordier soyez le bienvenus député
à partent et les républicains des
Ardennes et bonsoir Benjamin
sainte-huile
député Eliot du Nord donc 4 députés avec
vous ça fait 5 et Eric Coquerel
l'assemblée je le disais sous le choc
après cet acte
ignoble quand même nous l'expliquer
Stéphane blackovski qui nous rappelle
les faits on l'accueille tout de suite
et je me retourne pour vous accueillir
comme chaque soir chers Stéphane bonsoir
à vous Myriam bonsoir messieurs alors
que s'est-il passé bon bah l'agression
que il y a eu lieu à Annecy ce matin à
ville en sidéré la France l'assemblée ne
fait pas exception ce matin il est
pourtant les bagues extrêmement houleux
dans l'hémicycle autour de la
proposition de loi liotte pour abroger
la réforme des retraites et puis soudain
Mathilde de panneaux a pris la parole on
l'écoute
je voudrais dire l'émotion de mon groupe
face à l'attaque au couteau et aussi
enfants en bas âge qui ont été blessés à
Annecy
alors
je vous remercie madame la Présidente
d'avoir pris les devants
donc la présidente avait prévu
d'attendre la fin de la science donc
elle a demandé à l'ensemble des députés
de respecter 1000 de silence qui a été
vraiment très très solennellement
respecté oui mais voilà on est à
l'Assemblée et on fait de la politique
alors quand les chaînes infos nous ont
appris que celui qui avait poignardé des
enfants Annecy était un réfugié syrien
bien la politique a vite refait surface
bien sûr on a commencé chacun dans son
camp par exprimer froid émotion mais
vous savez que il y a un projet de loi
sur l'immigration qui devrait être
débattu bien toi l'assemblée vous savez
aussi que les LR ont des propositions de
loi sur l'immigration qu'il
souhaiteraient présenter donc
Eric Ciotti qui est le patron du parti
vite fait le lien entre le la question
de l'immigration et ce qui s'était passé
à Annecy on l'écoute et là un profil
issu d'une immigration qui aujourd'hui
pose un débat majeur et doit poser
ouvrir un débat majeur en Europe sur
notre capacité de choisir qui nous ne
voulons pas et qui nous voulons
accueillir sur notre territoire dans un
premier temps on a même le sentiment que
la LR réagissait plus dans la polémique
que Marine Le Pennel même qui dans son
premier tweet vous voyez on n'avait pas
de sous-entendu sur les origines parlé
simplement d'un individu armé d'un
couteau en fait du côté des Troupes de
Marine Le Pen assez rapidement on s'est
joint à
Erik sotti sur la polémique on écoute
Laure La Valette qui elle fait le
rapprochement entre ce qui s'est passé à
Annecy et une autre agression couteau
qui a eu lieu hier à Athis-Mons dans
l'Essonne on écoute hier c'était un lit
bien par exemple celui vous voyez qu'il
y a qui a poignardé le chauffeur de bus
dans
matière migratoire poser la question
voir comment est-ce qu'on gère ces
demandes d'asile on voit bien que cette
immigration dérégulée mais les Français
en danger bref à ce moment-là on se
croyait parti donc sur une journée où la
polémique sur le sujet allait monter en
puissance sauf que lorsque Elisabeth
borne est finalement arrivé à Annecy
vers 15h30 la situation avait quand même
un petit peu évoluée la preuve quand il
y a eu un point presse avec la procureur
la première ministre a souhaité
elle-même dresser le portrait robot donc
de l'agresseur
sans doute qu'elle était assez soulagée
de pouvoir annoncer que c'était pas un
clandestin que le gouvernement aurait
échoué à accompagné dans son pays avec
une aucutef non exécutée on écoute quel
est le profil de la grande sœur
un individu a priori isolé si rien avec
un statut de réfugiés accordé en Suède
il y a 10 ans et ce monsieur n'a pas
d'antécédent judiciaire n'est connu
d'aucun service de renseignement et on
n'a pas identifié dans tes dents
psychiatrique alors deuxième chose qui
est un peu modifié peut-être la nature
du débat la meilleure en certains
s'enflammait c'est que on s'attendait à
ce que un moment considère que c'était
un acte terroriste comme il a déjà eu
plusieurs en France de ce type là et en
fait la procureur dit que ce n'est pas
forcément le cas on l'écoute il y a
aucun mobiles terroriste apparent il y a
une évaluation qui est en cours comme
c'est l'usage dans ce type de procédure
par le parquet national antiterroriste
mais en l'état on n'a pas d'éléments qui
nous pourraient nous laisser entendre
que nous qui est une motivation
terroriste ce qui est frappant dans
cette agression sauvage c'est qu'au
départ il y avait vraiment l'idée du
stéréotype de l'attentat islamiste du
loup solitaire comme on a déjà eu en
France sauf que en fait c'est pas
exactement ça
l'assassin ou celui qui a voulu
assassiner dit qu'il est chrétien
d'Orient on a des raisons de le croire
d'ailleurs il a crié au nom de Jésus et
non pas Allahu Akbar au moment de
connaître son meurtre donc ça change un
peu le stéréotypes classiques de ce
genre de conversation ce qui fait que
finalement les LR qui avait prévu une
grande conférence cet après-midi sur le
sujet et bien on annule la conférence et
Laurent Wauquiez qui lui en tant que
président de région se déplacer aux
chevaux des victimes à préférer ne pas
en rajouter on l'écoute je pense que il
faudra qu'on se pose des questions il
faudra que on comprenne ce qui s'est
passé il faudra qu'on apporte des
réponses aujourd'hui juste penser aux
familles juste penser à ses enfants
alors bien sûr on a nos signes pensées
sincères pour les victimes leur famille
mais on est à l'Assemblée et donc même
quand un drame comme un sweet dance qui
se produit et bien on continue de parler
politique merci Stéphane Mathieu
Lefebvre aujourd'hui c'est le temps de
l'émotion c'est l'inimaginable quand
même qui s'est produit aujourd'hui des
bébés de moins de deux ans dans des
poussettes qui ont été à poignardées
nous sommes tous horrifiés par ce qui
s'est passé c'est détermination des
abominations je crois qu'aujourd'hui en
effet c'est pas le temps de la politique
c'est le temps du recueillement c'est le
temps de penser aux familles de victimes
c'est le temps de penser également aux
forces de secours qui sont intervenus
extrêmement rapidement aux passants qui
ont vu cette scène d'horreur donc de
grâce ne nous livrons pas de la
politique politique
quand vous dites les forces de secours
qui sont intervenues rapidement dans la
journée des questions ont pu être posées
sur ce point-là en particulier
mais moi j'ai entendu monsieur Zemmour
faire une vidéo absolument insupportable
voilà je crois que aujourd'hui le temps
c'est le temps du recueillement ce qui
veut pas dire que nous devons être naïf
en matière migratoire je suis pour mieux
maîtriser les flux mais ces sons ce type
d'amalga mais ce type de comportement
outrancier qui ne fait que desservir
l'intérêt général surtout dans une
journée de deuil comme celle-ci ce lien
avec l'immigration qui est déjà dans la
bouche de plusieurs de vos collègues
Eric ciottier on l'entendait je pense
qu'on réagit dans l'immédiateté et c'est
vrai que quand on fait de la politique
et qu'il y a des événements de cette
nature qui se déroule dans notre pays et
bien l'homme politique j'allais dire
avec un grand âge a tendance à en une
fraction de seconde sur les réseaux
sociaux et autres d'envoyer un certain
nombre de messages avec la
responsabilité que vous avez je pense
que il faut avoir du discernement j'ai
moi-même tweeté mais avec beaucoup de
prudents prudence quelques minutes après
ce sont un peu emballé à Olivier
Aurore berger la présidente du groupe
Renaissance a fait pareil quelques
minutes après en sortant devant toutes
les caméras je pense qu'il faut
parce que vous faites référence à un
autre sujet pour berger le voici la
saillant vêtu de verre coiffée d'un
turban serait un demandeur d'asile
l'immigration massive un contrôle il a
parlé bien trop tôt d'après tous les
éléments de l'enquête vous le
reconnaissez oui je pense qui c'est un
petit peu emballé mais vous savez dans
le contexte dans lequel on est
aujourd'hui dans la société dans
laquelle on vit on a toujours tendance à
réagir peut-être un petit peu vite vous
interrogerez directement le président de
notre groupe à ce sujet mais je de
l'autre côté quand il y a une telle
émotion je pense qu'il faut avoir un
petit peu de retenue prendre de la
hauteur et effectivement comme ça vient
d'être dit pensez aux familles et aux
gamins en question parce que là on est
dans le dans le summum de l'horreur je
j'explique à noter les spectateurs il y
a déjà 4 millions de vues sur la vidéo
de LCP sur hors berger qui elle est
sortie de l'hémicycle en expliquant
qu'il fallait évidemment dans la
circonstance arrêtez je cite les
batailles de chiffonniers on va parler
de ce qui s'est passé aussi sur la
proposition de loi un mot là-dessus
rapidement
politicienne sur berger je crois qu'il
était peut-être aujourd'hui un petit peu
dérisoire de poursuivre nos travaux
alors que ce drame nous a tous touché et
c'est ce qu'elle a voulu pas seulement
les gens de l'opposition vous êtes dans
la majorité elle a une responsabilité en
tant que présidente du groupe elle
devait aussi avoir un peu de
discernement comme tout le monde je
viens de le reconnaître pour ma famille
politique reconnaissait le pour la vôtre
Elisabeth borne a eu des mots très très
forts elle a saoulé l'intervention
rapide de la police elle a évidemment
une pensée pour pour les familles est-ce
que dans un moment pareil vous dites
c'est très important d'éviter toute
polémique
j'ai déjà une pensée pour pour les
familles évidemment non mais c'est pas
une histoire polémique ou récupération
je sais pas quoi les Français veulent
vivre en sécurité c'est quand même la
moindre des choses parce que ce alors
criminel assassin est-ce qu'il y avait
préméditation ou pas bon après tout
c'est un autre débat 8
ça faisait huit mois qu'il était sur le
territoire national 8 mois il avait
déposé sa demande d'asile au mois de
novembre d'accord alors on refuse on va
tout dire alors ça va
en 2013 alors effectivement il arrive en
Syrie il arrive en Suède de Syrie en
2013 sans doute en passant par
l'Allemagne merci handela Merkel il se
marie il a un enfant et il repart il
vient en France voilà alors pour
demander pour avoir une demande failli
dépose une demande d'asile déjà si on
avait été au pouvoir peut-être que dans
son cerveau de fou il a compris que nous
on veut instaurer les demandes d'asile
dans les ambassades et les consulats
c'est à dire à l'étranger et si c'est
accepté on vient en France il y a pas de
il y a pas de problème là-dessus
en Europe et là si je puis dire à cause
à cause de Schengen il a pu venir tout à
fait légalement si je puis dire en
France sans visa pour trois mois bon il
est resté 8 mois donc déjà là il aurait
dû être expulsé mais rien n'a été fait
donc il faut revoir Schengen enfin je
veux dire les frontières
parce que pour le moment l'enquête
d'asile au mois de novembre voilà ça
c'est factuel on a quand même mis 8 mois
avant de pouvoir il avait déjà fait une
demande d'asilement national à l'état de
l'enquête ça aurait pu être évité c'est
ce que vous dites ce soir c'est un peu
facile je suis factuellement je constate
et simplement pour terminer il faut
revoir les accords de Schengen les
frontières ça protège il y a eu la covid
on a mis des frontières donc ça sert à
quelque chose les frontières non le
programme de Marine Le Pen Benjamin
sainte-thuile c'est un donc un Syrien
qui a obtenu le statut de réfugiés je
l'ai dit c'est aussi un profil différent
chrétien d'Orient et se dit lui-même
chrétien de série on le dit il avait une
croix ça interroge
ou pas je crois que il y a des moments
dans la vie en général ou la parole est
d'argent et le silence est d'or et vous
avez relevé avec justesse que ceux qui
se sont empressés à essayer de faire de
ce drame une cause politique une forme
de triste fait divers sur lesquels il
pourrait capitaliser cela se retrouve
aujourd'hui entre guillemets pris au
piège parce qu'ils sont allés trop vite
je le dis je suis et père de deux
enfants qui ont cet âge-là je me sens
touchée j'ai pas envie de faire de la
politique politicienne si j'écoute le
collègue du rassemblement national
faudrait presque croire que si c'était
Marine Le Pen la présence de la
République ce genre de fait serait
impossible c'est un mensonge absolu
quand je lis le tweet de Monsieur marlex
je suis triste pour lui-même parce que
les républicains me donnent le sentiment
de n'être plus que sur eux cette boucle
migratoire pour essayer d'exister et
c'est vrai que la sortie de Madame
berger était inappropriée mais de
manière générale je suis pas là pour
donner des leçons je dis juste
taisons-nous il y aura le temps de
l'enquête des éclaircissements vous avez
des enfants qui sont entre la vie et la
mort vous avez des parents qui sont dans
une tristesse infinie dans une peur et
la responsabilité publique c'est aussi
quand on ne sait pas de dire qu'on ne
sait pas et qu'il est temps de se taire
et de respecter le chagrin
oui parce que enfin honnêtement j'en ai
un peu assez ça me rappelle Charlie et
tout on était tous et effondré mais
allumé des bougies mettre les drapeaux
en berne chanter la Marseillaise sur
cueillir et un moment stop les Français
ils veulent être protégés
tout ce que vous voulez ça c'est la
nationalité qui compte voilà la
nationalité il est pas français il est
syrien il est il a une demande d'asile
qui a été accordée mais avec plaisir il
peut circuler comme il veut en Europe il
y a un problème
de bus c'est un lit bien sous-oculaire
la petite Lola qui a été massacrée 12
ans
qui avait une occupé
nationale non mais vous ne faites rien
vous êtes d'un laxisme complet et c'est
pour ça que nous on progresse on va
terminer ce tour de table de toute façon
il y a une enquête qui est en cours il
va y avoir aussi un projet de loi
immigration et je pense que voilà les
campagnes à venir notamment les
européennes vont poser la question de
l'asile et du Règlement Dublin votre
votre réaction est Coquerel on est déjà
dans la récupération on va pas poser la
question de de cette personne bien
évidemment
nous-mêmes ne versez pas dans ce genre
de choses d'accord moi je crois
aujourd'hui que tout ce qui est
récupération politique du idéologique
par rapport à ce qu'on a vu ce matin
c'est totalement indécent voilà et que
les gens qui ont versé dedans on parlait
trop vite en voulant justement faire le
lien et essentialiser le geste de de
cette assaillant qui manifestement ça
faisait 10 jours qu'il irait dans les
rues d'Annecy se lavait dans le lac
d'Annecy et avec les caractérisations
à dire par exemple c'est le fait que 60
à 70 000 personnes en Île-de-France
aujourd'hui ont des problèmes
psychiatriques
de type marginaux et ne sont pas soignés
si on avait des choses à dire extrapoler
on pourrait dire ça mais essentialiser
les choses imaginez que parce que vous
êtes si rien que vous êtes réfugiés
parce qu'il a eu sa demande son droit
d'asile donc ça veut dire que ce droit
d'asile lui était reconnu certainement
par rapport à ce qu'il avait vécu
notamment en tant que chrétien en Syrie
que il a été que parce qu'il était
réfugié reconnu en Suède ça il
signifierait ça expliquerait son geste
c'est tout simplement absolument
scandaleux et de toute façon
plutôt que de réagir de cette manière de
ces éléments là très rapidement je
rejoins ce qui vient d'être dit
simplement quand on fait de la politique
on est là aussi pour proposer des
solutions à nos compatriotes le
commentaire c'est une chose twitter
facebook les plateaux de télévision
c'est une chose il n'en demeure pas
moins que nos compatriotes attendent de
nous quel que soit nos sensibilités des
solutions aux problèmes qui sont posées
et je crois que ce soir c'est ce qu'ils
attendent et c'est ce qu'ils notamment
dans le cas de de cette proposition de
loi ou de ce projet de loi on verra bien
avec chacune et chacun en fonction de
ses sensibilités qui pourra apporter une
pierre à l'édifice on s'arrête là pour
ce qui concerne ce qui s'est passé à
Annecy évidemment cette attaque elle a
contribué à abréger les débats ce matin
à l'Assemblée nationale on va s'arrêter
à présent sur ce qui s'est passé dans
l'émission les députés des battaient
donc de la proposition de Loi sur
l'abrogation de la réforme des retraites
vidés de sa substance le groupe Lyot a
fini par la retirer c'est en stress
agité vous allez le voir au cours de
laquelle les oppositions ont dénoncé une
rupture démocratique majeure compte
rendu Marco pommier
règlement rien que le règlement la
Constitution rien que la Constitution
c'est mon rôle et j'aimerais bien
aimé
applaudi par son camp hué par la nuesse
cible de la colère des opposition la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale a
déclaré irrecevable les amendements pour
annuler la retraite à 64 ans il
recevable sur le plan financier
l'opposition dénonce un déni de
démocratie vous abîmer vous écrabouillez
la démocratie parlementaire et vous
surtout il y a une chose que vous
oubliez c'est la séparation des pouvoirs
et la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale aux ordres de l'Elysée assume
de ne pas être la garante des droits du
Parlement mais la misérable courroie de
transmission d'un passage en force
ahurissant du côté de la nupette ou du
rassemblement national on est persuadé
que la majorité craint le vote
[Musique]
pour Marine Le Pen le gouvernement borne
mérite de tomber
voilà Mathieu quelle charge on vous
accuse si clairement on vous accuse de
piétiner le Parlement et même la
démocratie dans notre pays écoutez c'est
la fin d'une mascarade qui a été je le
regrette à alimenter par vous Éric
Coquerel qui avait été finalement plus
Mélenchon que président de la commission
des finances et c'est vrai que quand
vous êtes insoumis un jour vous êtes
insoumis toujours y compris à notre
droit fondamental la constitution du
général de Gaulle on peut pas tordre les
règles en démocratie on a le droit de
devenir majoritaire pour les changer
pour ça il faut se présenter aux
élections et devenir majoritaire et là
on peut changer la constitution c'est
drôle de vous citer la Constitution mais
de Gaulle c'est une pratique un esprit
et une lettre et c'était un peu l'idée
dans cette bataille des retraites et
d'attires 40 l'esprit voulait qu'on
l'utilise pas sur les propositions de
loi je ne crois pas et de ce point de
vue il n'y a aucun constitutionnalisme
qui est venu au secours de votre
interprétation sur le président Coquerel
aucun alors vous êtes mis en cause le
président Coquerel mais encore une fois
au-delà de ces arguments de forme qui
ont beaucoup de sens la question c'est
quel est le projet alternatif des
opposants à cette réforme monsieur
sainte-huile il a donné la main à la
fois mais il panneau et à Marine Le Pen
sans qu'elle n'ait besoin de se la
donner on est dans une majorité de rejet
il n'y a aucun projet alternatif pour
les Français alors
Eric Coquerel et ensuite Benjamin
politique mais c'est pas très grave si
vous pensez que la responsabilité du
président de la commission des finances
explique pourquoi sur une loi de cette
importance vous est débrouillé pour que
jamais l'assemblée note que ça soit avec
le 49-3 que ce soit je vous ai écouté
que ce soit avec le 47 ans que ce soit
maintenant avec une utilisation de
l'article 40 absolument rompant avec
toutes les traditions
permettant l'initiative parlementaire
depuis maintenant des années personne ne
vous croit Mathieu le fait personne ne
vous croit je peux faire votre exutoire
c'est qu'on a entendu un gouvernement
dire il sera hors de question que cette
proposition loi soit votée et vous avez
malheureusement oublié à ça vous le
faites et quand vous le faites je vais
vous dire une chose parce que peut-être
qu'un jour vous serez dans l'opposition
peut-être qu'un jour vous serez en
opposition cette fois-ci au moins le
gouvernement les autres fois c'était lui
qui était venu dans l'hémicycle nous
dire 49-3 nous dire que la proposition
de loi serait faite sous le 47 ans qui
permettait de réduire les débats et de
ne pas voter là vous avez vous avez
invité à mettre nous-mêmes notre tête
sur le bio avec l'article 40 vous avez
pris une décision vous cherchiez comment
à faire en sorte qu'il ne soit pas voté
parce que vous saviez minoritaire et
vous avez toute utilisé maintenant vous
m'attaquer personnellement une fois de
plus parce qu'en réalité
de nombreuses émissions sur l'article
vous n'allez pas tenir pendant 4 ans de
manière démocratique si vous ne
supportez pas qu'il y ait des
oppositions je vous rappelle
bien face à face uniquement monsieur
Benjamin s'intitule moi j'ai lu La
Tribune de Charles de Courson et
d'autres présidents de groupe dans le
monde qui dit que ce qui s'est passé ça
crée un précédent dangereux à l'avenir
pour l'initiative parlementaire en quoi
précisément
j'écoute avec intérêt ce que dit
Monsieur Lefebvre presque avec un ton
professeur oral je vous renvoie une
question combien de fois sous la 5e
République un amendement de
rétablissement une proposition de loi a
été considérée comme anticonstitutionnel
je vous donne la réponse 0 monsieur 0
tout ce qu'on est en train de discuter
là c'est un écran de fumée la réalité
c'est que vous ne vouliez pas voter et
l'autre réalité je vais terminer l'autre
réalité c'est que dans la situation très
particulière de majorité relative on est
en situation de considérer qu'après que
la présidente de la soirée nationale est
d'abord accepter la proposition de loi
elle est changée d'avis vous savez ce
qui s'est passé entre deux
vous le savez parfait pas du tout
monsieur vous le savez parfaitement je
vous propose vous allez répondre parce
que c'est vrai qu'elle a été ciblée tout
du long on va écouter un exemple de
critique extrêmement vif vis-à-vis il y
a le brun Pivet la charge elle était
menée par Sandrine Rousseau puis vous
vous répondrez sur les pressions
supposées sur Yelle Brown privé
le président n'a pas le droit d'entrer
dans l'Assemblée nationale pour
respecter la séparation des pouvoirs il
n'en a plus besoin il s'est assuré la
servilité d'un perchoir
et je précise que Jean-Louis boulanger
est monté ensuite à la tribune pour
dénoncer cette mise en cause de la
présidente toutes les oppositions y
compris vous Pierre Cordier vous pensez
que la présidentielle brune Pivet a subi
les pressions au plus haut de sommet de
l'État alors tout d'abord préciser que
moi je fais partie du des députés les
républicains opposés à cette réforme
puisque faut dire les choses nous avons
il y a un débat dans notre famille
politique et moi je fais partie
ce texte làbrogation évidemment je crois
que quand on fait de la politique il
faut être cohérent ce que ce que l'on
relève simplement c'est que en une
semaine de temps il y a El brune Pivet a
changé d'avis au départ elle a voulu
donner vie finalement à ce texte et lui
permettre d'être des débattus dans
l'hémicycle et on est bien on a bien vu
qu'en quelques jours les choses ont
changé moi je voudrais simplement
m'arrêter sur un texte que j'ai amené
ici une proposition de loi qui a été
déposée par Aurore berger et un certain
nombre de ses collègues de la République
en marche dont d'ailleurs enfin
Renaissance la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales portant
en mesure pour bâtir la société du bien
grandir en France qui a un texte qui
était adopté il y a quelques jours et il
s'avère qu'à la fin de ce texte à
l'occasion de l'article 14 de ce texte
il est précisé puisque ce texte a une
incidence budgétaire d'un peu plus de 8
milliards d'euros c'est quand même pas
une petite affaire et bien il est
précisé exactement la même chose que le
texte déposé pariotte c'est à dire la
charge pour l'État et compenser à du
concurrence par la création d'une taxe
additionnelle à la scie sur les tabacs
prévus au chapitre 4 du titre premier du
livre 3 du Code des impositions sur les
biens et services parce que simplement
quand il y a une proposition de loi elle
est toujours gagée sur le tabac ça a
toujours été comme ça donc
moi je lis simplement
de la parole juste après c'est vrai que
cette proposition doit elle a été jugée
recevable elle fait une charge dégagée
sur le tabac est-ce qu'il y a pas deux
poids de mesure
moi si demain parce qu'on peut rentrer
dans le débat technique si demain je
veux dépenser 5000 euros pour donner au
refuge de ma circonscription monsieur le
Président Coquerel
mais monsieur Macron disait il y a un an
et demi
est-ce que ce sont les mêmes règles pour
tout le monde si je peux m'exprimer
parce que voilà
démagogie si on peut juste répondre on
vous écoute je veux dépenser 5000 euros
pour les refuges animaliers de ma
circonscription le président Coquerel va
me dire vous n'avez pas le droit et là
Monsieur sainte-huile et ses amis qui
d'ailleurs au passage proposait la
retraite à 64 ans il y a quelques années
ils vont nous dire 15 milliards d'euros
pas de problème circuler il y a rien à
voir
qui qui coûte
pas une proposition de loi dégager comme
le tabac vous savez très bien que c'est
vous savez très bien que c'était pas la
même chose en réalité je vais vous dire
une chose ça fait maintenant depuis 2012
qu'il n'y avait eu aucune interpellation
venant de la majorité ou d'un
gouvernement
pour interpeller le président de la
commission des finances pour qu'il
rentre il recevable des lois qui
pourtant coûtaient aussi cher et qui
étaient gagé de la même manière la seule
raison pour lequel cette fois-ci vous
êtes en train de rompre la chose et
d'ailleurs le rapporteur général mais de
la commission au moins avec qui j'ai des
débats un peu argumentés le reconnaître
c'est parce que vous êtes prioritaire et
que la situation échangée donc parce que
vous êtes vous estimez que des
propositions de loi qui autre qui
passaient depuis des années avec des
dépenses tout aussi importantes que
celles qui est prévue et la même type de
gâche cette fois-ci on ne peut plus
accepter parce que vous êtes prioritaire
mais vous comprenez j'aimerais bien que
l'assemblée ne peut pas se faire selon
les désidérables
supposition d'accord de la part du
gouvernement et le gouvernement du
gouvernement
ce que vous nous dites et monsieur le
rapporteur le dit aussi bien sûr c'est
que s'il y a un signal du gouvernement
un signal
la
constitutions parce que j'ai une réponse
écrite de rapporteur si le gouvernement
n'avait pas l'article 89 4 cela suppose
qu'il peut être d'accord avec la
provisoire donc faut ce que vous nous
dites c'est que le gouvernement
l'initiative parlementaire doit
dorénavant et elle ne peut s'autoriser
qu'à partir au moment du gouvernement
est d'accord et bien c'est tout
l'inverse c'est tout l'inverse
depuis des années clairement il y a une
règle du jeu à géométrie variable parce
que mon collègue Cordier 6 cet exemple
me heurtait un peu le pain de la bouche
parce que j'avais le même
on l'a bien délire depuis quelques temps
proposition c'est la géométrie variable
et vous c'est pas non plus de mauvais
choix qu'on assiste depuis des semaines
voire des mois maintenant de la part du
gouvernement de la part de la majorité
alors ce qu'on a appris quand même
aujourd'hui parce que faut le relever
quand même c'est que l'exécutif a un
relais auprès du pouvoir législatif avec
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
on devient une drôle de démocratie
il y a eu pression enfin tout le monde
il y a eu des articles de presse j'ai lu
des journaux
c'est pas mais non lisez la presse
franchement lisez elle est revenue en
arrière puisqu'elle voulait faire vivre
la démocratie dans l'assemblée c'est
elle-même qui l'a dit et d'un seul coup
bon bah voilà
pressions retraites sont publiés la
plupart le match est terminée vous
attendez 2029 que le déboucher on
revient sur cette funeste loi et on
revient à si vous voulez parce que moi
j'entends dire il y a pas de
contre-proposition si en 30 secondes
nous on est pour la retraite si on
commence à travailler avant 20 ans 17 20
ans vous partez à 60 ans on revient à 62
ans à jegal et après il y a des annuités
pour ceux qui ont alors Monsieur
alors attendez parce que là on met le
pays quasiment pour combien pourquoi 10
milliards d'euros c'est même pas un demi
points de PIB c'est même pas un mini
coin de PIB alors non non mais attendez
il faut tout mettre en perspective le la
dette
600 milliards on va emprunter 270
milliards sur les marchés financiers et
le budget c'est 165 milliards de
déficits là c'est 10 milliards 2000
points de PIB 68 milliards d'économies
68 milliards par mois sur 20 milliards
sur l'immigration
alors là aujourd'hui d'accord on voter
on aurait voté votre proposition de loi
donnez-moi alors vous et vous alors vous
le joueur je vous réponds financier
comment je vous réponds monsieur nous
avons fait des propositions nous sur la
CSG nous avons fait des propositions sur
l'emploi est-ce que vous souffrez
d'argumentaire qui vous qui vous
conviennent pas à augmenter
les oppositions s'expriment ici non mais
Monsieur le problème ou pas c'est pas
une question il faut je me dis
simplement que nous sommes contre
la solution
va s'appliquer que vous le vouliez ou
non il n'y a plus de recours
parlementaire Benjamin saint tuile les
insoumis vont déposer une motion censure
la dernière fois vous en aviez posé vous
étiez à l'initiative le groupe liote
elle avait rassemblé
les insoumis qu'est-ce qui va se passer
vous vous mettez vos signatures avec
celles d'alafi je crois que le groupe
fera ce qu'il a toujours fait il
laissera la liberté d'appréciation au
parlementaire et je veux prendre un sans
quand même souvent dans l'hémicycle
quand il se trouve et c'est
régulièrement le cas au regard du
comportement de la majorité relative que
les oppositions sont coalisées on a des
collègues qui nous disent regarder vous
votez ensemble les uns les autres mais
il faut quand même dire les choses s'il
y a deux vices présidents du
rassemblement national dans cette
boutique c'est parce que vous parlez le
notaire de la macronie avait voté pour
ses vices présidents le contestait pas
monsieur vous seriez ridicule c'est
juste une fois
pas de leçon
pas de leçon pas de leçon je vous
remercie
est-ce que vous allez
vous voir à cette motion insoumise ou
pas
à l'origine et vous étiez bien d'accord
pour que tout le monde vous rejoigne il
a déjà sur la question des retraites
déposer une motion de censure elle a
échoué à 9 voix absolument aujourd'hui
une situation est-ce qu'on peut parler
monsieur ça va c'est dur la démocratie
c'est bien écoute c'est difficile chacun
peut s'exprimer tranquillement allez
c'est terminé si les collègues de la
nupaise décident de déposer une motion
de censure ils sont tout à fait légitima
à le faire et dans le groupe sans doute
il y aura des collègues qui le voteront
pas mais il faut dire les choses moi je
ne crois pas que cette notion de censure
aboutira à ce stade si vous appelez pas
votez
les liottes sont tous là on a vu que
c'était pas il faut dire les choses
clairement le gouvernement et les
carbonisé la méthode elle est zéro
incapable de créer le compromis et c'est
ça la réalité ils ne savent pas ce que
ça veut dire la majorité leur hâtive ils
ne savent pas ce que ça veut dire faire
un pas vers l'autre d'ailleurs quand
vous discutez encore sur ce plateau et
qu'on vous dit qu'on n'est pas d'accord
je pense que sur cette notion de censure
les républicains je pense qu'il y aura
aussi chez les républicains indé bas
comme il y a eu la dernière fois il y a
des gens qui sont pour cette réforme
d'autres qui sont contre vous savez dans
la droite républicaine il y a toujours
eu une droite libérale et une droite
plus gaullistes sociales moi je fais
partie des gaullistes sociaux je crois
en l'humain je veux placer l'homme au
cœur de cette de cette réforme et pas
forcément se focaliser uniquement sur
l'aspect budgétaire surtout quand on a
3000 milliards de dettes et quand on a
un déficit budgétaire rien que sur
l'année 2023 de 150 milliards d'euros et
là on parle simplement de 13 milliards
c'est ça que les gens ne comprennent pas
non plus sur le terrain on leur parle de
Somme pharaonique et à côté de ça la
réforme des traites c'est 13 milliards
tout ça pour faire plaisir aux agences
de notation qui n'ont pas forcément été
très sympathique
on va voir ce qui va se passer dans les
prochains jours si cette motion aboutit
qu'il a vote qu'il a votre pas la page
des retraites est tout doucement en
train de de se tourner mais on verra si
cet épisode laisse des traces ou pas
c'est le risque que vous prenez Mathieu
Lefebvre avec avec la majorité merci
beaucoup beaucoup merci d'être venu
débattre vous restez avec moi Éric
Coquerel dans une dizaine de minutes les
parties pris de nos affranchis ce soir
Vincent Huget grand reporter va revenir
sur la situation en Ukraine après
l'attaque du barrage tout près de Carson
et puis dans l'oeil du numérique de
Delphine Sabatier et bien on essaie de
nouvelles lunettes ce soir les lunettes
Apple Vision Pro apparemment c'est pas
terrible on voit ça tout à l'heure mais
d'abord on va parler de vous
Eric Coquerel ça fait bientôt un an que
vous pilotez cette commission des
finances vous êtes imposé à entendre
beaucoup de vos collègues même si la
crise des retraites a élargi le nombre
de mots d'ennemis on l'a entendu il y a
un instant et bien regardez c'est dans
l'invitation Marion Becker petit
portrait et on discute juste après
si on vous invite
Eric Coquerel c'est parce que vous êtes
l'un des personnages clés du dernier
feuilleton de l'Assemblée sur les
retraites en tant que président de la
commission des finances tous les
projecteurs étaient braqués sur vous
avec cette interrogation
alliez-vous déclaré y recevable la
proposition de loi d'abrogation de cette
réforme des retraites et bien non non
malgré les pressions ironie du sort vous
défendez la proposition d'un homme qui
n'a pas approuvé votre nomination il y a
un an Charles de Courson s'y serait bien
vu et lui comme d'autres doutait de vos
compétences depuis vous avez su
convaincre à ce poste crucial
d'ordinaire confié à une personnalité
modérée vous êtes même reconnu par vos
opposants il s'est bien mis dans son
habit de Président il est courtois
respectueux je dirais à la fois de
manière collective vis-à-vis des groupes
politiques et également de manière
individuelle assez attentionnée
finalement aux députés aux membres de la
commission des finances comme président
de la commission
équilibré juste drôle de destin pour un
homme qui a été annar à l'adolescence
pendant vos années étudiantes pendant 15
ans à la Ligue et communiste
révolutionnaire avant votre rencontre
avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon en 2008
député depuis 2017 vos engagements
restent intacts modérés sur la force
mais radicale intransigeant sur le fond
défenseur des classes populaires des
quartiers l'un des premiers de votre
partie à lutter contre l'islamophobie
aujourd'hui vous voilà sur un siège
éjectable le fait d'avoir validé la
proposition de loi d'abrogation de la
réforme des retraites a provoqué le
cours ou de la majorité
et ce qui va bien c'est que là il a
piétiné sa fonction en faisant cela j'ai
rien contre le l'homme en particulier
c'est simplement voilà il fait passer
ses convictions politiques avant
l'intérêt général de l'institution et ça
je n'accepte pas vous pourriez ne pas
être renouvelé à la tête de la
commission des finances en octobre alors
on a une question pour vous Éric
Coquerel vous sentez-vous vraiment
menacé
réponse certains menaces en tout cas
mais j'ai remarqué pour l'instant en
tout cas j'ai le plaisir de voir
qu'aucun commissaire de des finances
quel qu'il soit à prophété ce genre de
menace
c'est vrai qu'en général les
reconditions sont assises tous les
postes clés à l'Assemblée vont être
renouvelés c'est le cas chaque année
cette fois-ci pour y avoir un vote une
première vous me direz cette majorité
fait beaucoup de premières
inédite mais ça voudrait dire plusieurs
choses ça voudrait dire déjà que il
faudrait trouver quelques autres
opposition qui est envie de jouer un
rôle de
perdez moi l'expression de de position
croupion c'est à dire être l'opposition
qui va bien à la majorité c'est pas ça
que ça sert un président de la
commission des finances pour et puis il
faudrait aussi que la majorité vote ce
qui n'a jamais été fait parce que si
c'est pas le cas il y aura la même vote
que la dernière fois ce qu'ils veulent
un vote et je serai de nouveau élu j'ai
même l'impression à écouter certains que
il y a une reconnaissance un peu plus
générale absolument mon rôle Président
c'est très notable
vous auriez fait le même reportage je
pense que vous n'auriez trouvé aucune
critique donc qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
c'est que simplement je n'ai pas voulu
accepter les déshyracas de la majorité
sur quelque chose que j'estimais injuste
c'est-à-dire de déclarer y recevable une
proposition de loi dont la jurisprudence
faisait qu'elle devait l'être elle
devait être recevable et on a bien
compris que vous l'assumez vous ne le
regrettez pas mais donc il faut ça ça
renvoie quelque chose je pense que je
parle très sérieusement je pense que la
majorité est arrivée à un moment où il
faut qu'elle accepte des oppositions
voilà il faut qu'elle accepte que des
gens ne soient pas d'accord avec elle et
donc en l'occurrence un président de la
commission des finances et le seul il y
a pas d'autres présidents qui soient de
l'opposition parce que c'est un
contre-pouvoir ce qui a d'ailleurs voulu
législateur vous êtes sceptique sur le
fait même d'intégrer qu'elle n'a pas la
majorité absolue
de le faire à vos yeux on verra bien moi
ce que je sais c'est que tout le monde
n'entonne pas le même discours j'ai
entendu quand même dans la macronie tout
le monde ne dit pas la même chose donc
j'espère que il va pas y avoir d'autres
lignes rouges de franchi mais je vous
dis encore faudrait-il trouver une
opposition qui accepte de jouer ce rôle
là et je ne suis pas du tout sûr de ce
résultat donc je regarde ça on verra
bien quand je veux pas vivre la règle
est dans le changement de l'Assemblée
elle revient cette présidence de
commission des finances à l'opposition
et ça ça ne va pas changer pour vous ça
a changé quoi d'être présidente de
commission c'est une commission
absolument stratégique elle est très
puissante vous regardez les budgets mais
pas seulement
c'est plus compliqué qu'être dans
l'opposition clairement
ça me permet c'est une commission qui
est intéressante qu'on touche à tout en
fait et on touche absolument à tous les
sujets puisque tout est financier donc
du coup on peut développer déjà des
connaissances des pratiques une
connaissance aussi de de ce qu'il faut
faire en termes financier économique et
autres bon j'avais déjà un bon bagage
quand même parce que militants
politiques depuis très longtemps donc
militants politiques vous intéressez à
l'économie mais c'est clair que ça m'a
ça m'a permis de m'enrichir et puis
c'est bien non mais en plus je suis
naturel comme ça vous savez moi je viens
du rugby etc j'aime bien j'aime bien le
collectif et c'est vrai que c'est aussi
un plaisir d'essayer de à la fois
mettre ma marque alors ma marque ça
passe par exemple par rapport à des gens
que jauditionne
qui qui sont à un moment qui vous a
marqué dans c'est un an de commission
s'il devait y en avoir un j'en ai
plusieurs j'ai fait en sorte qu'une par
exemple une mission spéciale c'est
chaque il y a des missions par qui sont
définies par budget et qui sont donnés à
des rapporteurs spéciaux et j'en ai
proposé une pour Charles Leduc sur
l'évasion fiscale bon ça c'est quelque
chose qui est un peu ma pâte
c'est-à-dire que non il y a quelqu'un
qui tous les ans travaillent là-dessus
et puis c'est aussi la le fait de donner
parents pas des commissaires spéciaux le
soin d'avoir des cartes des cartes
blanches ils invitent qui veulent pour
parler de sujet alors c'est des sujets
très différents ça peut venir les
bailleurs sociaux d'autres c'était sur
l'économie de montagne etc et puis enfin
bah là par exemple on va auditionner
Pisani ferry dans peu de temps la
présidente de France Télévision
donc j'essaye de diversifier diversifier
les gens que nous auditionnons voilà
c'est aussi et puis il y a aussi les
autoroutes où je me suis un peu je me
suis un peu débrouillé pour que le
dossier révélé par les cadres enchaînés
monte un peu en puissance sur la façon
dont les les concessionnaires
d'autoroute avaient largement profité de
la privatisation et j'ai vu que ça
avançait donc vous voyez c'est aussi ce
genre de dessous donc vous pesez il y a
un impact on le sent à regarder de près
les budgets les réformes de ce
gouvernement est-ce que vous rejetez
tout en bloc de la politique économique
d'Emmanuel Macron les chiffres de
l'emploi sont tombés ce matin et ils
sont encore bon hein c'est l'Insee plus
0,3% c'est le 9e trimestre en hausse
c'est pas rien d'avoir fait vraiment
baisser le chômage non oui alors il faut
regarder un peu plus précisément c'est
pas c'est pas pour vous l'année mais je
vois aussi que on est dans la sixième
puissance économique au monde et on a
pas encore de pauvreté comme on n'a
jamais eu
j'observe aussi ce que disent les
statisticiens sur le chômage par exemple
aujourd'hui malheureusement ceux qui
sortent du chômage est plus des gens qui
se désinscrivent mais qui ne sont plus
sur le marché de l'emploi plutôt que des
gens qui cherchent un emploi c'est aussi
le fait que pendant que depuis
maintenant un an on a changé les
statistiques on compte les gens qui sont
en apprentissage et vous savez que
l'apprentissage est une politique
massive qui a voulu ce gouvernement à
mon avis au détriment des lycées
professionnels mais c'est une autre
question
des emplois créés le sont directement au
CDI ça ça change l'emploi industriel
aussi repart
industriel
oui il a retrouvé le niveau de 2015 je
dis ça parce que on a on a comme ça des
des annonces de chiffres qui ne
correspondent pas à la situation
économique du pays d'accord ce qui a
aussi c'est un pouvoir d'achat en berne
et des salaires qui ne suivent pas
l'inflation ce qui fait que les gens de
plus en plus de mal ce qu'il y a aussi
c'est une crise de logement
une crise de nos services publics
bonhomme maland notre économie elle crée
250 à 260 000 emplois par an des emplois
ça peut être quelques heures par semaine
d'après l'Insee donc je trouve que le
bilan d'abord il est pas meilleur que
d'autres pays européens et il est pas
aussi mérifié que le dit le gouvernement
et je crains d'après ce que dit aussi
l'Insee que les que l'avenir soit moins
rose que ne le prétend
le gouvernement Emmanuel Macron parlons
un peu de la France insoumise votre
mouvement vous le fidèle entre les
filets de Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous faites
partie de ces insoumis qui ont été
écartés de la coordination du mouvement
vous l'avez bien vécu ça bon je dis ce
que j'avais à dire à ce moment là et
puis
oui oui parce que je me concentre sur
des questions qui me semblent plus
important je dis pas que les questions
de d'organisation démocratie ne sont pas
ça m'intéresse mais moi j'ai toujours
fait le choix de de travailler
il intervient
juste c'est vrai que par exemple si on
regarde aujourd'hui je préfère
concentrer mon temps sur la question de
la me poser à la réforme des retraites
etc que à la vie interne de France
insoumise c'est pas que mon préoccupe
pas c'est que je suis obligé de
hiérarchiser parce que j'ai qu'une vie
je comprends tout à fait et c'est là que
ça se passe aujourd'hui l'assemblée est
au cœur du pouvoir désormais mais il
intervient beaucoup dans cette vie
parlementaire sans siégé Jean-Luc
Mélenchon se souvient de son fameux
tweet sur l'article 7 la volonté de
continuer à vous faire entendre la
colère certains diront l'obstruction
franchement vous vivez bien ça ça vous
met pas de mal à l'aise
de stratégies au moment d'article 7 par
des débats bien évidemment bien
évidemment on peut être d'accord ou pas
d'accord mais c'est normal on est un
mouvement avec 75 députés très
certainement le plus gros mouvement
politique de ce pays en termes de noms
d'adhérents donc fort heureusement vous
voudriez quoi qu'on soit tous alignés
je vais répondre dans notre groupe nous
votons donc c'est bien voilà qu'on n'est
pas forcément le même avis et puis après
on fait des bilans il y a une ligne qui
a certains moments l'emporte enfin
souvent c'est uniquement tactique c'est
pas des grandes questions stratégiques
moi ça je veux dire c'est l'inverse qui
me poserait problème bon et quand à
Jean-Luc moi je l'ai toujours dit je
continue à considérer que Jean-Luc
aujourd'hui une autre leader voilà il y
a de français soumise même si il s'est
mis avec un pas de côté mais n'empêche
pour l'instant c'est lui qui d'un point
de vue stratégique programmatique et
tribunicien continue à nous représenter
le comportement possible en plus c'est
mon ami diriger tout ça fait que non ça
ne me dérange pas que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
interviennent ce qui ne m'empêche pas y
compris quand des fois je pars des
différences et bien de le défendre dans
les réunions de groupe et autres et
c'est pas pour ça qu'il m'en veut donc
il aura je ne sais plus exactement mais
75 ans en 2027 et donc est-ce que il est
temps de passer évidemment est-ce que
vous souhaitez qu'il soit candidat moi
j'ai dit que là aujourd'hui ici les
élections présidentielles arrivaient
maintenant parce que lui-même met la
question du temps la question de
voilà de notre de notre finitude quelque
part dans la balance dans ce qu'il
pourra être fait assister aujourd'hui je
pense que ça serait le notre meilleur
candidat et pas François Ruffin c'est
pas la relève non je me dis aujourd'hui
je vous dis ça on verra bien ce que
voudra dire à Jean-Luc dans les mois à
venir quels sont le même seront les
circonstances et puis après c'est
parfait parce que figurez-vous nous
sommes plusieurs Françoise
[Musique]
j'apprécie beaucoup François on a des
discussions des fois on n'est pas
toujours d'accord mais c'est parfait je
trouve que c'est bien qui quelqu'un qui
qui justement comme ça monte en gamme il
y en a d'autres on est plusieurs à le
faire je pense d'ailleurs vous voyez
vous parlez je pense qu'on est plusieurs
à monter en gamme c'est parfait et on
verra bien toute la gauche mais moi je
vais vous dire 2027 c'est terminé
là-dessus c'est que aujourd'hui là ce
qui me paraît le plus important pour
gagner en 2027 c'est le fait que la
nupaisse continue à être ensemble sur un
programme de rupture parce que c'est ça
ne pèse pas seulement unité c'est sur un
programme de rupture
à l'Assemblée nationale mais on voit que
vous avez chacun aujourd'hui puisque
c'était des élections législatives et ça
marche drôlement bien l'assemblée vous
nous avez vu faire un serment
aujourd'hui dire que nous abrogerons la
réforme cette réforme et que nous
reviendrons vers la retraite à 60 ans
donc nous disons des choses ensemble moi
j'ai bon espoir et en tout cas je crois
que c'est nécessaire parce que c'est la
condition pour pouvoir remporter ces
élections et si on est ensemble on
pourra l'emporter et dans ces cas-là
viendra le temps de savoir qui
lequel
classique merci c'est bien d'avoir le
programme avant c'est ce qu'on a fait
une journée en 2012 et en 2017 et en
2022 je vous propose à présent
d'accueillir nos affranchis pour leur
parti pris vont vous faire réagir
Vincent Huger bienvenue grand reporter
spécialiste des questions
internationales de l'Afrique mais aussi
de la situation en Ukraine et et puis
Delphine Sabatier bien sûr de bismart
qui a mille et lunettes d'Apple donc on
verra ça dans un instant on commence
avec vous Vincent ce soir alors le
secrétaire général de l'OTAN
jenstenberg a présidé une réunion en
visioconférence une réunion autant
Ukraine cette semaine et il a évidemment
été question de l'ainéantissement du
barrage dans la région de Kerson et de
ses conséquences alors la destruction du
barrage hydroélectrique de Nova kakovka
un ouvrage d'art colossal mais en
service en 1956 donc autant de l'Ukraine
soviétique est avant tout un désastre
humain et une catastrophe écologique
faune et flore bien sûr il est trop tôt
pour dresser un bilan des inondations
dantesques qui ont submergé les deux
rives du ni pro la revue Ouest sous
contrôle de Kiev et il arrive est tenu
par les forces russes deux certitudes on
comptera le moment venu des morts par
centaines et les naufragés évacués en
barque ou en canaux par milliers quant
aux mines baladeuses dispersée déplacée
elle tueront et mutileront bien après
que les canons se seront tues côté
environnement il faudra des années voir
des décennies pour effacer les stigmates
d'un tel cataclysme notamment du fait de
la pollution massive des eaux du fleuve
qu'il s'agisse d'eau potable ou de
celles que requiert l'irrigation des
cultures et que dire des espèces
animales décimées poissons oiseaux et
rongeurs et militairement alors les
conséquences de ce désastre il y a
paradoxalement rien ne prouve que cet
épisode dévastateur s'il en modifie la
topographie infléchira le cours de la
guerre ni qu'il entravera lourdement la
contre-offensive
ukrainienne seul constat à ce stade
élargir le ni pro comme les vastes
espaces maracajeux qui le franchent
jusqu'à son delta ses raccourcir un
front s'étirant sur un millier de
kilomètres et d'une certaine manière
sanctuariser au prix fort et pour un
temps la Crimée une telle submersion
complique non seulement le
franchissement du fleuve mais aussi la
reconquête par les Ukrainiens de la
péninsule annexée en 2014 les experts
militaires s'accordent sur un point à
l'instant T et même si elle a aussi
anéantie des ports entiers du dispositif
défensif russe la cata de Nova kakovka
gêne davantage Kiev comme Moscou ça
suffit pour un criminer forcément les
l'occupant
enfin les forces d'occupation de vladir
Poutine gardons nous de céder au réflexe
pavloviens fameux encore un coup des
Russes et tout autant à la tentation
cartésienne jusqu'à l'excès du quui Bono
à qui profite le crime il n'empêche
passé au tamis de l'analyse rationnelle
les éléments factuels dont nous
disposons un site à juger hautement
probable la responsabilité de
l'agresseur russe ces troupes occupent
le barrage de la centrale depuis février
2022 pour venir à bout de cet ouvrage
cyclopéen un pilonnage de l'artillerie
ukrainienne c'est la thèse du Kremlin
n'aurait pas vous suffit et il aurait en
outre perclus d’éclat les vestiges de ce
titan de béton or rien de tel sur les
images visionnées on connaissait la
tactique nihiliste de la terre brûlée
sans doute assististe-t-on à la
résurgence de la politique de la terre
noyée résurgence audite donc il y a des
précédents historiquesment beaucoup en
41 par exemple après la rupture du pacte
Germain soviétique Staline ordonne le
minage du barrage de zaporriggia tiens
donc histoire d'enrayer l'avancée des
colonnes de la Wehrmacht laquelle agira
de même à l'heure de la débâcle dans le
nord-est de la France au Pays-Bas et en
Belgique avant cela mes 43 les pilotes
de la force bombarde les ouvrages de la
vallée de la roue ils entreront
d'ailleurs dans la légende sous le
sobriquet de dames Busters les briseurs
de barrage dès la première guerre
mondiale on avait recouru c'était en
l'automne 1914 en Belgique à cette
technique de ce qu'on appelle
l'inondation défensive c'était lors de
la bataille de l'Isère en clair rien de
bien nouveau sous le soleil blafard du
Nipro merci beaucoup Vincent on
connaissait les crimes de guerre de
Poutine maintenant on a les crimes
d'écocide dans ce conflit
pas les guerres c'est souvent une
catastrophe écologique et ça a toujours
été mais là en ce moment évidemment
c'est encore plus fort moi ce que je
crois c'est que on est dans une
situation
on le voit bien où on est sur une ligne
de crête très compliquée c'est à dire un
de faire en sorte que Poutine de gagne
pas c'est de guerre bien évidemment
puisque c'est l'agresseur donc la
perdent en tout cas dans ses objectifs
qui sont ceux d'envahir son voisin et
puis en même temps
d'essayer de laisser une chance à
réglement plus tard Pacifique et de ne
pas généraliser un conflit dont qui
évidemment serait encore plus tragique
d'un point de vue humain mais aussi d'un
point de vue écologique c'est ça la
question qui nous est posée aujourd'hui
on va laisser du temps pour terminer à
Delphine Sabatier alors vous avez suivi
la conférence de presse d'Apple Delphine
elle a présenté une innovation changer
carrément sans s'échanger carrément nos
vies expliquez-nous vision mais vous ça
ne vous fait pas rêver manifestement et
pourtant je suis plutôt assez bonne
cliente pour les innovations donc là on
a découvert dans un moment relativement
solennel comme Apple c'est bien le faire
un tout nouveau produit de la marque à
la pomme il s'agit d'un casque de
réalité mixte que dis-je de l'avènement
de l'informatique spatiale alors
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça la réalité
mixte alors déjà cette réalité mixte
peut-être pour comprendre le plus simple
cette partie de ce qu'on commence un peu
à comprendre et à connaître c'est la
réalité virtuelle on a tous vu des
gamers porter des casques sur les yeux
qui sont totalement immergés dans les
univers factices d'une partie de jeux
vidéo vous avez peut-être même vous-même
des images de réalité virtuelle par
exemple sur la construction de la
cathédrale Notre-Dame de Paris alors à
chaque fois dans ces cas là avec la
réalité virtuelle on est coupé du monde
or là avec la réalité mixte ou augmentée
et bien on mélange le réel et le virtuel
on va être capable d'apposer par rapport
à la scène qui se passe devant nous des
images des applications là par exemple
ceux qui nous regardent sur LCP sur leur
téléviseur depuis leur salon et bien si
le portait le casque il pourrait tout à
fait à côté du téléviseur projeté je
sais pas des photos leurs mails pas
besoin de sortir un smartphone ou un
ordinateur on fait comme ça flotter dans
l'espace la charge mentale la visuelle
ça fait beaucoup numérique d'accord donc
vous nous dites que ça peut changer nos
vies c'est ça oui alors déjà c'est un
faut quand même dire que c'est un bijou
technologique c'est vraiment une
prouesse c'est absolument époustouflant
la qualité d'image qui est promise par
Apple dit promise parce que pour
l'instant on est encore sur des
démonstrations en laboratoire mais
attention Apple n'est pas simplement là
en train de nous montrer un nouveau
produit il est en train de nous dire je
suis profondément en train de changer
nos usages numériques carrément
carrément c'est donc ce qu'il
spatiale donc c'est en gros on a connu
l'informatique personnelle avec
l'ordinateur l'informatique mobile avec
les smartphones et là d'un seul coup on
va voir cette informatique un peu
partout donc spatial pas dans l'espace
là haut mais dans nos espaces dans notre
environnement donc il y a plein d'usages
fabuleux qui vont émerger dans plein de
domaines professionnels mais alors au
quotidien faut voir à quoi ça ressemble
alors montrez-nous s'il vous plaît on
regarde les petites publicités qui ont
été diffusées par Apple au moment de
cette conférence il y a par exemple ce
papa qui est tout seul sur son canapé en
train de regarder en boucle on nous dit
pour bien s'en souvenir des images de
ses enfants quand ils étaient petits
alors c'est quand même assez triste moi
toutes ces scènes de de d'expérience
nouvelle vécue qu'elle soit réelle ou
virtuelle vécu à travers un casque c'est
flippant presque ça m'a pas du tout
moins fait rêver ça va pas du tout
donner envie vous allez me dire déjà
avec nos smartphones on vit beaucoup
derrière des écrans là on va traverser
notre vie à travers des écrans la bonne
nouvelle c'est quand même que ce bijou
technologique n'est prévu que pour début
2024 aux États-Unis au prix de 3500
dollars donc ce qui n'en fait pas un
objet du quotidien ça nous laisse le
temps quand même de méditer sur ce futur
ça vous tente ou pas les lunettes moi je
pense que les rapports sociaux les
rapports humains c'est ce qui nous
définit entre en tant qu'être sociaux
des humains et si à un moment donné ces
rapports disparaissent au profit de ce
genre de procédé nous serons plus nous
serons plus les mêmes et je pense que
c'est ça qui qui doit nous interroger et
en plus je voudrais dire quelque chose
c'est que on voit bien tout le
développement à ce moment l'intelligence
artificielle des réseaux de tout ça moi
ce que je trouve c'est qu'il n'y a pas
pendant l'éducation à l'école par
rapport à tous ces outils voilà je pense
que ça explique beaucoup de problèmes
actuels savoir comment les gérer comment
s'en écarter comment les gérer je pense
que là dessus on est très en retard et
ça explique pas mal de dérives tout à
fait vertigineux merci merci les
affranchis Vincent Huger à très vite
Delphine Sabatier la semaine prochaine
sans doute et merci à vous ricoquerel
d'avoir passé l'heure en direct avec
nous c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi tout de
suite votre soirée documentaire
Jean-Pierre Gratien à demain
[Musique]